[Music]
Today in history, on July 22nd, 1456,
the West scored one of its greatest
victories against Islam and in so doing
inaugurated the ringing of church bells
at noon.
[Music]
One month earlier, in late June 1456,
Sultan Muhammad II's massive Ottoman
army, the same that had conquered
Constantinople, three years earlier,
reached the strategic fortress city of
Belgrad or Belgrade.
Located at the confluence of the Danube
and Sava rivers, the city stood as the
gatekeeper of Christendom's heartland.
Both Muslims and Christians understood
the stakes. If Belgrad fell, Hungary and
much of Europe could easily soon follow.
Muhammad encircled the city by land and
river.
His camp sprawling across the headland
turned the landward approach into a sea
of Turkish tents. From the water, 60
galleys and 150 smaller warships choked
the fortress.
Many vessels were chained together,
forming a wall against any Christian
relief attempts.
On July 4th, the anniversary of
Saladin's victory over the Crusaders at
Hatton in 1187, a bad omen for Belgrad,
Muhammad ordered his artillery to begin
its relentless bombardment. The thunder
of cannon echoed for 100 miles.
After 12 days, gaping breaches appeared
in the city's walls.
>> I already conquered Constantinople 3
years ago. Now I vow to take Belgrade,
then Buddha, and the whole of Hungary.
Nothing can stop me.
>> Meanwhile, John Hunyatti, a seasoned
Hungarian general and veteran of battles
against the Turks, was preparing his
relief force. His professional army was
small, outnumbered by Muhammad's elite
guard alone. Yet swelling his ranks were
tens of thousands of peasants crusaders
inspired by the fiery Franciscan frier
John of Capistrano.
These were not professional soldiers,
but common folk, farmers, laborers, and
beggars, drawn to the cause of Christ
with fervor. As one chronicler observed,
>> the world has turned upside down. The
lowliest of the low are the ones now
defending Christendom.
>> And Sylvius, the future pope pas I
described this unlikely multitude. From
the depths of Europe they came barefoot,
ragged, unshaven, each holding a loft a
crude cross of wood or iron, crying not
for riches or land, but for vengeance
against the enemies of Christ.
Although Hunyatti doubted their
effectiveness, there was no time to
hesitate. On the night of July 14, the
relief force launched its desperate
mission along the Danube. Munyatti's
makeshift flatillaa moved toward Belgra
while Capistrano and his peasant army
advanced by land. As they approached the
Ottoman naval blockade, cries of Jesus
Jesus rang out and the Christian ships
slammed into the presence. From within
Belgrad, the defenders joined the fry,
sending their own ships to break the
line. A savage river battle erupted,
lasting five bloody hours. The
Christians ultimately shattered the
Ottoman blockade. Several large Muslim
galleys sunk, others were captured, and
the rest burned by Muhammad himself to
prevent their seizure. The Danu was now
in Christian hands. Supplies,
reinforcements, and morale surged
throughout the battered city.
>> Yet, the siege intensified. Ottoman
cannons positioned closer than ever,
unleashed all hell on Belgra. By July
21, much of the city's defenses lay in
ruins.
But the real trial was only beginning.
Inside the city, Kunyatti found the
garrison demoralized. He rallied them
with a fierce exhortation. What fear
you? Is this the first time you have
seen the Turks? Are not these the very
same we have so often put to flight, and
who have sometimes put us to flight
also? Why should their familiar aspect
disturb you now? Be of stout heart. Put
your trust in Christ. Did he not die for
us? And should we then accounted a
hardship to die for him?
>> Capistrano added his own fire to the
defenders, crying,
>> he who dies today for the cause of the
cross shall wear a martyr's crown in
heaven. Let not one of us be found
lukewarm.
>> At dawn on July 22nd, the Sultan gave
the order for the final assault.
>> Allah Akbar, attack.
Drums thunder. Kettle drums boom with
the janiseries. Elite shock troops of
Islam charged the breaches shouting
Allah Akbar. Promised paradise and
virgins. Whether they lived or died,
they poured into the seemingly abandoned
citadel. But it was a trap. Hunyatti had
concealed his men in rubble and alleys.
The signal was given. The defenders
burst forth.
Halfastrono's peasant crusaders
descended from the walls. The Turks
caught between inner and outer defenses
were ambushed from all sides. Street by
street, tower by tower, a brutal melee
unfolded. Though outnumbered and poorly
armed, the Christians fought with
desperate fervor.
Kunani himself fought in the thick of
the fray.
Oh,
>> women joined the defense.
[Applause]
One legendary moment saw a Christian
knight Titus Duggovich embrace a Turk
attempting to plant the Islamic crescent
honey tower and hurled both of them from
the parapet to their deaths. Still the
Turks kept coming. Arrows darkened the
skies. Cries and chance mingled in
death. The defenders pushed to the brink
made a final stand. A top a watchtower.
Capistrano, now 70 years old, held the
cross aloft and cried out,
>> "Oh Jesus, where are thy tender mercies
which thou hast shown to us of old? Oh
come and aid us and tear not. Save, oh
save thy redeemed, lest the heathens
say, where now is their God?"
Then the Christians unleashed all hell.
They hurled pitch, tar, burning wood,
and sulfur onto the mass Turks in the
ditches and scaling the walls. Flames
engulfed hundreds. Then thousands. Panic
spread through the Ottoman ranks,
screaming. Some leapt from the walls
into fire. Others were cut down trying
to flee. Tagalia, who witnessed the
scene, recalled,
>> "None could flee from the face of the
fire. All who were in the ditches, the
multitude whereof no man can number
consumed. Not one of them remained
alive."
>> The Turkish chronicler bitterly noted.
They made a furnace of the battlefield,
turning the flames of hell against the
warriors of the prophet. A thousand
Janisaries fell in fire and smoke and
the smoke of their martyrdom rose to the
heavens.
As dawn broke on July 22nd, the
battlefield was a charred graveyard.
Ottoman corpses filled the breaches,
ditches, and approaches. The Sultan's
elite guard was annihilated. Still,
Hunyatti kept his men alert. Another
attack was expected.
[Applause]
The Turk is never more dangerous than
when he is in difficulties.
>> Recalling bitter lessons from earlier
battles he had lost against the enemy at
Varna in Kosovo.
[Applause]
A small band of peasant crusaders
ignoring orders clashed with Turkish
scouts. The skirmish escalated as more
crusaders joined. Even Capistrano,
unable to restrain the mob, was swept
into the tide, exclaiming,
>> "The Lord who made the beginning will
take care of the finish."
>> Seeing the movement, Bunyatti and his
core troops surge into battle. The full
Christian host poured out of Belgrad
shattered walls and met the enemy poking
battle. Despite the chaos, their
momentum was unstoppable. In the MLE,
even Sultan Muhammad was seen fighting,
swinging a jewel encrusted scimitar. Yet
his presence could not halt the
unraveling. Christians captured Ottoman
cannon and turned them on the Turks.
Panic became contagion. The Janisaries
battle hardened began to break.
[Applause]
>> The Sultan flew into a rage threatening
to impale their commander Hassan Beg.
Hassan in disturb charged the enemy and
was promptly pieces.
Now the Ottoman line collapsed.
Muhammad, wounded and furious, was
finally convinced to retreat. Dragging
his wounded body and shattered pride, he
fled. Pursued for 8 miles by pursued
troops. Once confident of subjugating
Hungary, he now limped back to Adrian
Opople in disgrace. There, enraged, he
ordered the execution of units that had
fled Belgrad first. When all was said
and done, and according to contemporary
sources, some 50,000 Ottomans lay dead.
An additional 300 cannons and 27
warships were lost for Christendom. It
was an astonishing victory. In a letter
to his absentee king, Hunyatti wrote,
"Never before has a Turkish sultan been
so ruinously defeated. All across
Europe, from Venice to Oxford, church
bells rang and bonfires blazed. Pope
Kixstus III overjoyed established a new
tradition. Daily ringing of church bells
at noon. A practice that survives to
this very day, including in some
Protestant churches, though few of any
denomination, including Catholics,
remember its origin. The Pope in a
letter to Christian princes, declared,
"God himself hath shown his favor to the
cross and turned back the armies of the
infidel. Let no prince of Christendom
henceforth excuse cowardice, for even
peasants with pikes and faith have
triumphed over the sword of a sar." It
was, as one observer put it, a triumph
of the lowly. The peasants of Europe,
long thought helpless against the
Ottoman tide, had reversed the fate of
nations. Never in history had such a
horde of beggars and surfs overcome the
most feared army in the world, one
German chronicler wrote. Surely the
finger of God was upon them. But
celebration quickly turned to mourning.
Plague had broken out in the wake of the
siege. On August 11th, John Hunyatti,
the warrior who had held the line for
Christian Europe, died in Semland. When
he had begun to sense death, he insisted
on being carried to church for his final
communion. It is not meat that the
master should come to his servant, he
said. It is for the servant to go and
seek his lord. He died shortly after
receiving the Eucharist. 10 weeks later,
Capistrano also died. The double law
stunned Europe. As one chronicler put
it, the whole world was deeply disturbed
by the death of the one upon whom the
hopes of freedom and peace of
southeastern Europe had rested. Even
Yand Duggash, the often critical Polish
chronicler, admitted that Hunyatti's
death was detrimental not only to
Hungary, but to the entire Christian
world. There was no one else among the
Hungarian princes and noblemen to lead
the struggle against the Ottomans with
the same enthusiasm. He wrote, "The
siege of Belgrad was not merely a
military clash. It was a civilizational
confrontation. The armies of Islam
marching under the banner of jihad met
the remnants of Christrysendom in a last
stitch defense. And despite all the
odds, it was the cross, not the
crescent, that prevailed on that day in
history.